hello this is another one of dr sadler's
talking talks and the series that i've
started in order to answer questions at
greater life that have been posed to me
in other forums sometimes through email
sometimes through vu or other electronic
media
the question that i'm going to tackle
today and
we'll only get two you know so far into
because we only have
10 to 15 minutes
is a very contested one should religion
be taught in public schools and
one of my vuser friends
asked me that question it prompted a lot
of other questions
about k-12 education and church and
state and all sorts of other related
issues so i wanted to talk about this
this is something that i have given a
lot of thought to i used to teach not
only philosophy but also religious
studies in a college setting
and i would often be called upon to come
into local high schools
as i have done here in fayetteville to
give talks about world religions
now you might ask how can that be done
why should that be done doesn't that
violate the
separation of church and state
those are very valid questions and
those are things which want to be
explored i think that there's a lot of
misinformation out there about this
topic
and so one place to begin with one of
the issues to start with
is the constitutionality
is it allowable to teach
anything pertaining to religion
in a public school
it's very clear from supreme court cases
that you can't hold religious
observances you cannot require prayer
you can't even offer an opportunity for
a moment of silence because that may
make other students feel uncomfortable
as if they're being discriminated
against
so how can you actually teach about
religion
in a public school
well the supreme court actually
considered cases like this
in the course of discussing cases
where there had been some clear
infringement
on some of these constitutional rights
under the first amendment
and uh two of these cases that are
particularly
interesting engel versus vitaly
and abedin versus hashem
there were discussions uh you know these
are sort of side notes but they are
revelatory of an attitude that the
supreme court has towards a certain type
of teaching within respect to religion
in angel versus battalion you find
an assertion that the history of man is
inseparable from the history of religion
so
we'll come back to this in a moment what
that means is that if you're going to
adequately teach
the history of humankind you have to
have some room in there for teaching
about religion and if you're going to
teach it well
you have to teach the parts that pertain
to religion well
you know or else you would be teaching
an ideological perspective if you were
to try to strip religion away entirely
that would not be adequate teaching
in uh
evidence versus shem
justice brennan in a concurring opinion
wrote the holding of the court today
because they were holding that you could
not require
bible teaching
as such in public schools he said the
holding of the court today plainly does
not foreclose teaching about the holy
scriptures or about the differences
between religious sex and literature or
history
indeed whether or not the bible is
involved it would be impossible to teach
meaningfully many subjects in the social
sciences or the humanities
without some mention of religion now
what does this mean
well you notice he's talking about
several different
classes
you can teach
religious texts and you can teach
about religious movements about
religious ideas
about mindsets about tenets of religion
in a variety of different classes you
can teach about them in literature
classes or you know
english classes you can teach about them
in humanities
you can teach them about them in history
and you can teach about them in social
science those are all mentioned
explicitly
now why would you want to do that
so here's one of the questions
that i'd like people to think about
what would be lost
or what would be diminished
in a child's education
k-12
by not teaching about certain topics
well you know you leave a hole
in their education
and if it's just a matter of teaching
certain facts perhaps those holes could
be filled in later on
but
consider what education is
is education merely learning a bunch of
different facts which then you put
together in any way you like
no it goes beyond that
what else is involved in education
well
there's learning certain skills certain
dispositions certain
attitudes certain
modes of being
modes of behaving
you learn for instance how to do
research or at least i hope that you do
you learn certain technical things how
to use computers
but you also learn about what we call
the great ideas
the sort of
facts if you want to call them such
around which other
things coalesce
so for example
if you want to understand why the
pilgrims came over here to the united
states
you need to know something about
religion and not just religion in
general
but about christianity and not just
christianity in general
but about what was going on in the
church of england and on the continent
the european continent in terms of the
protestant reformation
you in order to understand
the mindset and really in order to fully
understand the writings
and the illusions and the arguments of
some of the pilgrims and some of the
puritans you need to know something
about calvinism
and you need to know something about the
church of england and its developments
and in order to do that you need to know
something about the roman catholic
church against which they were all
reacting
and in order to do that you need to know
something about the differences between
them and where are they
where they split off from each other and
why
you notice you need to know a lot of
things in order to make sense of that
one phenomenon
we could go on and on and on
if you want to understand the cultures
of the world
you absolutely have to know something
about certain major world religions
you need to know about islam
you need to know about hinduism
you need to know about buddhism
you also need to know about
some of the
religions that are that are peculiar to
particular ethnic groups like chinese
folk religion
that helps understand a lot of things
confucianism not you know originally
starting out in china but deeply
influencing japanese culture
and korean culture
so to deprive a child
of learning about those things is really
to stymie
and to set back their education
is to generate somebody
who is whether they like it or not
in some ways an ignoramus
you deprive them of some of the major
things that they need in order to pick
in order to constantly
ideas conceptions
historical movements
you know
and
i'm not saying that you have to supply
them with something like a
comprehensive education in world
religions but you have to provide them
with something otherwise you are in fact
in some way doing those children harm by
not fully educating them
there's a distinction that we can make
that gets made in these supreme court
cases that's very important to keep in
mind this is
why a lot of people are very
uncomfortable with the notion of talking
about religion in schools because they
don't make a distinction between
teaching religion
on the one hand
which would mean
taking a particular stand that a
one religious group or one subdivision
of that group has got things
fundamentally right
and teaching those texts as if they are
you know revealing absolute truth
and teaching
here's the key word about religion
there is absolutely no problem in
teaching about religion as a matter of
fact
in these supreme court cases they are
affirming that you ought to be teaching
about religion and if you are not doing
so
and you're not doing so in a competent
manner you are actually depriving
students of a full education
um
what does it mean to them to teach about
religion this is what we call the
religious studies model
we don't commit ourselves to truth
claims
we can make truth claims along the lines
of buddhists believe that the four noble
truths are true
and we can say here's what the four
noble truths are all life is suffering
etc etc etc we can we can actually
require students to to engage in rote
memorization of them but we're not doing
catechism we're not saying you must
memorize these because these are true
we're saying you must memorize these
because this will help you understand
the mindset the culture the arguments
the claims made by this entire group of
people
and that's something valuable
you're not committing yourself to the
truth of buddhism or the truth of
christianity or whether the roman
catholics have got it right about say
the authority of the pope or whether the
protestants have got it right you're not
actually making truth claims about that
what you are making claims about is that
it is true that such and such a group
believes this practices this that this
is an important value for them
and i like to stress this in terms of
the difference
between understanding
and agreement
i used to teach religious studies in a
maximum security prison
and i found that the students were very
interested in talking about religion and
they would always want to get into
doctrinal disputes about who's actually
right and i would say well we can't
we can't decide that here that's not
what we're going to do
it's enough just to try to understand
and really if you study any of the
world's religions what you do find out
they are so complex there's so many
things going on in them they have so
many texts so many interpretations so
many rituals such a wide universe of
meaning
and such long histories full of people
debating about these very things
that just to try to acquire
understanding
that takes a lot
so just to acquire understanding of why
hindus might say that god manifests
himself
throughout time under different guises
that's something worth exploring that's
more than a class session that could be
an entire week just going into that and
going into the intricacies of the notion
of the avatar
you don't require anybody to agree with
you
you don't require anybody to say i
believe this
and
that is what we're going to do in class
and i'm comfortable with it because it's
reinforcing or pushing onto others or
proselytizing about my beliefs
now people may feel threatened by
talking about other religions but so
long as you're not actually requiring
them to change their beliefs to change
their views
that's fine
what are some of the problems well
do we have teachers who are capable to
do this i think in large part the answer
is
no
unfortunately
high school teachers middle school
teachers they have to study a lot of
other things some of them may have
acquired the sort of education that you
find in religious studies
but many of them have not and they would
feel rightly uncomfortable in trying to
introduce this sort of thing what do i
think is a solution bring in experts
bring in people for guest lectures
provided they can they can say that they
are not going to
stress truth claims and that they are
going to focus on understanding
instead of agreement and they're not
going to proselytize bring in the people
who have degrees in religious studies
and philosophy of religion even those in
theology because if somebody is good in
theology and they're not you know just a
um
they ought to be able to explore and
explain other perspectives
i can talk more about that perhaps i'd
pull in another one
here's one of the questions i want to
leave off
intolerance
what should we do about intolerance when
we're teaching about intolerance
obviously we don't have to make truth
claims that you know they are right in
being intolerant
or that they are wrong in being
intolerant
but how do we teach about it that's a
question worth exploring
how do we teach about it without being
intolerant ourselves towards those who
have
discrimination of different ones who say
some people are right some people are
wrong that's a bigger issue and that's
one that has to be explored further i
believe there are some very good
solutions to it but i'm going to leave